good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it has been such a
long break maybe our our longest ever
perhaps and it doesn't end here we're
about to embark on our longest yeah ever
because we have just a crazy week coming
oh my god in my head
it's heavy do you know what I mean you
know sweetie
your head is heavy when you have a lot
on your mind oh no you have a heavy
heart it's bad no I just I'm so [ __ ]
busy my life is in shambles I don't have
a clean pair of underwear I have to go
to Target today to underwear because my
life is in boxes well it's all very
exciting there it's all happening you
guys because after today's show and
today's gonna be an incredible show
because so much interesting news
happened over the break it's like they
knew we were on a break and they wanted
to break all the news and they knew that
like last week we were like grasping at
straws so they better trust it's not
gonna be long before we're not allowed
to say that phrase really yeah that's
how [ __ ] nuts the world we live in is
it's so crazy and I'm like it's such a
joke I hope I hope that there's always
so people who like consider the war on
straws a joke ya know
how have we so tenacious I'm gonna make
a business card claudius right
influencer morning Peabody award-winning
morning show host thinks the wars on
straws is a joke still uses plastic
straws what's so funny is that Adams
paper cup at our place of work they
didn't get rid of classic stress yet
that I saw in the bathroom door this
morning that they are but they got rid
of elastic cups because they probably
still have stock so they're not gonna
throw them away you know right that
would feed directly into the ocean oh my
god just like what a cup of work what
was the last time we the last time we
spoke it was Thursday it was right
before I got Compton's like I legit have
not been here in forever I've been here
and I haven't worn makeup since Friday
and well I'm so jealous which I actually
I think that's the longest I've ever got
in my life without wearing makeup it
felt really nice but like I look the
same you know I thought my skin would be
radiant glowing but it's like I'm the
same I think a lot of water
seltzer which counts oh I wanted to even
update because I told you that I think
every room in TV jeez house in the
Hamptons is like a continent it was it
was a continent our contract country
sorry
so I state me in been stated T V G's
house in the Hamptons we had such a good
time like honestly I never could
and good quality time with CPG because
he's like the busiest person ever like
at best we had a night out together but
it was just nice like spending the day
with him and I just like did you learn
anything new about him I mean I just
continue to be impressed by him like he
is the most impressive person a great
and I really just want to like I want to
shove him in the face of our viewers and
I am because like just I was just
learning I don't even remember what we
were talking about but I was just like
learning so much about him in his
business and like I just have never
cease to be amazed by how impressive he
is did you learn anything new about the
credit card points world that we must
know because a couple of the tips that
he gave us back in February have changed
my life of course Delta shopping I know
know I know
I'm sapphire like pay for my flight to
Utah in a few months
sapphire is cool but like now it's like
regular so I think that TBG I don't know
this for sure I'm just like making it up
from honestly when I stuff them into
stream stories I believe that he is
developing an even bigger partnership
with Chase to come up with like even
more ways to help Eleni I'll say that's
what I think wow I'm a millennial and I
need to be saved so I am so millennial
this morning with my top dossier
I brought my trusty romper to I stayed
in Tokyo which was like so Tokyo there
was like crazy wallpaper the big map of
Jersey why it was kawaii yeah it was
very Tokyo and there was London there's
a loft
I forget what country that was it was
just epic
we gotta take the toast to Tokyo for
like three Autopia um also today's a
very special day because we have someone
who took out a personal ad on the show
and that's never happened before but
literally someone took out a billboard
not the billboard this billboard dad
yeah so we have a message that we need
to deliver because we are a personal ad
right now from Jesse crooks which is
just a tough left name you know but
whatever and it's amanda cooks his wife
i don't think you know this yet but it's
your anniversary oh wait we should get
this right read the message verbatim
because it's confusing and that's why
Jesse wanted us to deliver the message I
have an idea to surprise my wife for our
one-year anniversary she's really the
greatest thing that has ever happened to
me and I couldn't think of a better way
of surprising her than to have you two
ladies break the news to her last year
in September first we tied the knot if
in a few days later we went to Jamaica
for our honeymoon
little did my wife know that I had
planned a surprise after our Jamaican
vacation and I planned on us going to
Disney World for a few days
I placed I had everything planned from
dining with Disney characters to the
park hopper passes
whatever I don't know unfortunately my
surprise wasn't able to happen because
of the hurricane Irma oh [ __ ]
just days before I should have read this
before I didn't read it just days before
we were going to leave Orlando I got an
email saying that our flight was
canceled I was so disappointed because I
put so much time into planning this and
then it was cancelled so Jackie and
Claudia I'm wondering if it wouldn't be
too much to ask you to read this email
on your Wednesday morning show the
number one morning show very Intune if
that's necessary JC JC Jesse because on
Thursday morning tomorrow Amanda you're
going to Disney all right what are they
saying
in the Superbowl no mom I'm going what's
next I'm going to the New World
- Amanda wow that's so exciting
congratulations Amanda on your trip to
Disney I'm kind of jealous except we're
going ham toast like I'm not jealous by
the way poor planning Jessie if you say
you're a toaster why would you take your
wife away on camcos weekend totally it's
not like it's your anniversary or
anything anyway speaking of CAM toast
this is how it's gonna go down next week
after the show today we embark on camp
toes it's gonna be like just an amazing
road trip make sure you're following the
morning shows Instagram because we will
be storing all day
just lots of premium content hashtag ham
toast all weekend now we will be doing
camp we will be doing the morning toast
live from kam toast in the rec hall for
our toasters and we will be recording
those episodes for our patreon channels
so if you are really missing the toast
patreon.com slash the morning toast and
it'll all be there for you so and then
when we get back from kam toast it is
versus Shawn on the Jewish quarter here
here and I'm just so excited I was
actually thinking last night like this
is a new year and like how did my year
ago I was thinking like it's just way
that there's a - New Year's cuz like
there's the real New Year's and then
there's Rosh Hashanah but this is more
like a spiritual New Year's yes and like
you're forgiven for your joy your
soundless I feel like for January first
New Year's I think about like what I
want to do better in my life health-wise
yeah more like material tangible things
but this rush of Rosh Hashana I'm like I
think about like how I want to be a
better person
totally on the inside out I'm like what
is it goes from Russia Shana which means
in Hebrew head of the year so like the
start of the year and then a week later
is Yom Kippur which is like the saddest
day the Day of Atonement
so it's like you're really supposed to
just like repent for your sins I feel
like we're pen is not a Jewish word it's
a word is it yeah I just feel like it's
automatically like a Christian word I
just feel like I was
this is my story yesterday you know it's
it's all for the greater good so it's
their word I'm sure they kind of been
borrowing think and by the way not
really borrowing because we were first
but whatever I'm not gonna go split
hairs yeah so then it's like you start
this new year and then you just like
repent the [ __ ] out of yourself and then
you really start brand new and the agape
forgives you for your sins that you
committed in last year so you have a
totally clean slate unless you like
murdered someone that I think he's done
with you but unless you're not actually
sorry yeah oh that's true
like Justin Bieber so anyways I'm taking
a good look at myself on the inside yeah
what what do you want to won't even fix
well I actually was thinking like I feel
like on the inside I had a bit like a
good year I think I like Who I am but I
definitely think I could just I could I
could always improve yeah you know would
you like um a note sure oh you know what
I think I mean I know you so like I know
that you're a nice person but you like
you give off an unfriendly vibe not that
you are unfriendly but like you're a
little scary but to you like strangers
like you know like anybody you know like
you are like when you open up you're
like a sweetheart and you're like a gem
but like nobody knows cuz you're like a
little scary on your shell you know what
I think it's like I want to be scarier
because because it's like I feel like
I'm always getting pushed around like I
feel like people are always taking in
guys finish last nice guys finish last
and it's like I feel like I put up with
so much like I never complain like and I
want to be even scary and I don't think
that reflects like my like okay but I
just I feel like I don't want to be
pushed around as much as I am like I
need to like be more aggressive that's
the word John I think what I want to fix
is I really need to stop talking [ __ ]
about people and like I always say that
blushin Hara Russian Hara lawmen hey go
to hell the easy way like that's what
they say I just like I feel I find
myself saying like some terrible things
about people behind their backs I'm like
and every now and then like I would mean
a book my friend Abe we're out of
wedding and I like was for something and
he was like that is so mean and I was
like it is and then I listened to it
like it was in it was like such a mean
thing to say and like I really just want
to stop like cuz now I talk [ __ ] about
me all the time like on the internet and
like I happen to read it and like it's
mean and it's hurtful and I can just
imagine like it's just not nice and I
really do want to stop I trash it for
you
so yeah Russian Arduino is a sin but
like sometimes I have really mean
thoughts I don't say them but does that
make me
that person no if you don't say them
when we rap I will tell you this thing
that I said to Abe and he was like he
was floored and I guess I'm just like so
conditioned to myself being such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like it's not good like it took a
nice person to like realize he was like
yeah I'll tell you what it was so mean
but you know was mean when you said it
or like him saying he was the thing I
was just like you know when you're
people watching we were like at a
wedding with people that we knew and I
just like I just said something about
this couple and and by the way I was so
true it's so funny and like in a really
mean like stand-up show it would be
hysterical
but like Abe was like yeah but then
sometimes like I see something that I
don't mean as mean whatsoever like I
think it's totally benign and then
someone interprets it as mean like what
I said to Margo the other day what you
say like when we were talking about
praying oh how your whole life is a
prank the end Korean friend we're
pranking people like a week ago and
Margo tink had a prank phone call
because um she like had his number by
the way I did have his number so that
doesn't fit to the köppen anyways then I
said to Margo like you didn't get
pranked because your whole life is okay
like I feel like we're always pranking
it was how I meant it but she really
basically was like your life is a joke
and don't take it seriously that's how I
took it right but so so I'm sorry that
you thought you interpret in that way
but that wasn't the sentiment - no no of
course not a forceout I mean but that's
not something you need to fix cuz that's
just other people misunderstand me I
just need to work on the way I
communicate your communication yeah
wait also we have to talk about one more
thing before we grab because there's we
have women before we still haven't even
started there's a video going viral of a
girl at the US Open tipping her chicken
fingers in her soda and my friend Alexa
send it to me um in the DM z-- and I was
like oh my god lol yo and she goes no
Claudia that's me and I'm like wipe so
go back to the video was Ambar school
had two million views this was like
really early on and [ __ ] Alexa is
that the u.s. open with her neck it was
our friend Alexa Greenfield she is
dipping her [ __ ] chicken finger in
her bound soda and I was like oh and
then once I saw the video it's
everywhere so my guys everywhere barstow
like uncovered who she was and she's
like so pretty and so skinny in there
like she's a smoke show you know bro
and she's like doing in the news ever
she's been be an ESPN today that's
saying good for her good for her she
said that like she doesn't do like is
something she used to do when she was a
kid and she like doesn't really do it
ever but she was determined a fuse and
she like was playing with em and she
like was playing a prank on them almost
and she was like look what I'm doing and
they literally caught it on camera
videoed it though a cameraman like I've
been watching me but someone from the
from me is on TV
got it okay I saw maybe like a bar stool
san was like was wild like between
between me takes a like show people the
US Open like eating food and they just
happened to have got in her at the worst
possible moment and it's so funny I
can't believe how much it's blowing up
you know her
we know her well and I'm just I feel
like it's I love stories like that like
the nine stories that go viral it's the
Mason Ramsey of it all mm-hmm and like
so far there's no negativity even though
people are saying she's a serial killer
and then they want to call the police
but that's just funny like the oh my god
it's hysterical I get that she's getting
both positive and mean comments but why
because she's like a girl who's like
skinny and pretty like everyone's be
nice yeah it's like once they find out
who she is it's like it's epic yeah it
makes it even better that he's like so
hot it's not yeah not just crazy people
totally take their chicken fingers it's
so disgusting I was like when she told
me I'm like what I was like why you know
the video is honestly [ __ ] epic
totally okay also not only we have all
the stories that you need to know this
morning we have Viviana from Orion Jax
why we have to watch this later and I'm
so goddamn excited you guys left amazing
questions I have so many questions for
her like I'm just like I mean I've met
her but we were drunk and now I really
want to talk to her yeah we have to hop
to and Italy I need to talk to her about
Lauren s what do you mean ask her
they were together at the Super Bowl and
yeah what is she up to I feel like she
went back to normal life I feel like she
has a boyfriend she has a job and she
never left for the show and all seems to
be going right with her and her Gucci
sneakers okay without further ado here
are the fast side stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast and get
on this to cam toast okay first story
that is just shaking the world to its
core the next Bachelor Colton Underwood
okay
there's so many Colton's and every time
I say colts when I say Colton Haynes
same so just for I feel like that name
wasn't popular literally until a minute
ago and by the way there are so many
Under
Carrie Underwood right Frank redwood
yeah but I've been doing this a lot
lately and I don't I know it's like a
religious thing and like it's kind of
sacrilegious for me to be doing it cuz
I'm not Catholic but like it's more of
like a comedic tool I agree and if you
don't do the actual if you go the wrong
way then it doesn't count
what's the wrong way like I think it's
top down left right right left no but
it's just like I don't know I can't
count I'm not doing it I'm just like
it's just funny sometimes yeah I agree
okay so Colton is our bachelor they
announced it on GMA and right before
they announce it on GMA they had a
silhouette of a man silhouette tube of a
man scaramouche scaramouche can you do
that the end and go wait oh my god sorry
I'd say one more thing about Gigi's
okay so TB G's friend John was there who
was like the most epic person have you
met him like you would love him and he
works on Broadway like he works for the
Broadway's Union I forget what the name
is but he's like Barry he's just loves
Broadway and so like him and I were just
like a living [ __ ] like I was singing
show tunes the Hobie that's a great
beast like be our guests in the pool so
epic sorry I just want to share that
with you Oh
so gia what that was it yeah so GMA they
put the silhouette of because your
conversations engine so they had like
they didn't they weren't revealing it
yet they just had the black like cutout
of the person I just want to say
something
Colton hangings oh no Colton Underwood
has no neck no he's a no-neck monster
well then you were younger we like all
had posture problems and we call each
other no-neck monsters and Franklin the
Turtles yeah no and they are third the
turtle
Franklin who's Arthur Arthur isn't years
yes yeah yeah and the fist
anyways Colton is the bachelor and if
you follow me on Instagram which you
absolutely should you know that I am
here for it for a number of reason you
are in the minority I am in the middle
he's like up in our the toasters aren't
family not well I'm worried about them
I'm worried about the group and it's
like there are the toasters who like are
just talking about all the time and then
there are their toasters who are like
don't want to talk about it it's great
you guys we can't let Colton break us
apart Lee we can't let a man come in
totally right that's the first rule of
'girlcode
totally but I just feel like first of
all whoever The Bachelor is ever it's
like not really a big deal it's always
it just it has it hasn't not been a
disappointment for people since Ben
Higgins like it's always a
disappointment and they are just trying
to keep up with the times
and stay relevant young and current and
I think holding checks a lot of boxes
for that to be news did like a think
piece about how he's like middle America
Heartland heartthrob the heart brought
the Heartland heartthrob yeah and he'll
cater to that that demographic also he's
really young so we're gonna get a young
batch of girls gonna get corinne raven
alexis buds we're gonna get lauren
Amanda vibes because Ben Higgins was 20
to get to and he went on bachelor and
I'm here for that and they also just
want to say like when Colton went on
Becca season like he was such a catch
like yes now being on the show he is
like not even selling the show being on
paradise like ruined him and he never
should have gone but like he is a decent
guy like mind you he was in the NFL and
everyone's like oh my god you never good
loss let the bench like I don't care
once you're in the NFL like you are an
account player it's like finches
watching Friday Night Lights and I watch
and like none of those players made it
to the NFL they could barely make it to
college football so good for Colton he's
actually a catch like I could see why
all these women in America would be
lining up to date him yeah no totally
it's a Jesse Palmer era Nick vile had no
job right was 35 was just like a failed
reality set her and a bachelor like a
bachelor is someone who is like desired
right the first bachelor ever was like
Alex Michelle he was like a French
businessman and it's like yet we want
some level of like Matt I'm striving to
yes you know there hasn't been a
bachelor who is like fancy rich man and
so long that like Colton checks those
boxes I think what people are annoyed
about which i think is like [ __ ] up is
the Virgin thing and it's not so much
that it he's a virgin it's more so like
that it's just gonna be talked about
non-stop and that is annoying because
they beat any good thing to a pulp but I
just think it's like I don't even
believe that he is a virgin but I just
think it's like so sweet because they've
been virgins in the past but it's mostly
girls like Becca Tilly Ashley I Emily
Maynard Johnson the greatest woman we
had a virgin
oh just didn't have sex with sorry kind
of kid she's a baby
ya know she wasn't interested in Brad
Womack which totally understandable she
was also like a nice girl
I love how like in the entire history of
The Bachelor there was only one girl who
openly was like I'm not gonna have sex I
think we just met and like she was like
a rarity like lol that's just so I'm
indicative had braved our society is but
I don't know it's like nice and also it
sound like he's 50
he's 24 like okay is it a little odd yes
but it's it's fine it's nice I'm here
for it like it's fine I'm just not here
for them talking about it all the time
the only thing I'm watching I don't
think he has like so much relationship
experience meaning so I don't know that
he's ready for marriage but like no one
who goes on that show is necessarily
there to actually get married so yeah
I'm okay with that and also as we learn
from Raven on the toast
he's like Sean Lowe not all three women
sleep with the bachelor hmm
not even this dryer up sleeps with it I
think that Raven did not Raven came in
second and she admitted here exclusively
on the toast that she did not have sex
with Nick by oh hey Chelsea did not have
sex with me come with me file also I
know that um Kayla Quinn did not have
sex with Ben Higgins but I do believe
that Lauren and Jojo both did because
they both really thought they were gonna
win all right so it's not like a
prerequisite for all fantasy suite dates
and I just don't think it's a big deal
some Sean boy was a born-again virgin
everyone's like stop calling him a
virgin he he like had a you know
yoghourt moment every he was a
born-again merchant but he didn't sleep
with the girls on his season either and
he had one of the best seasons and has
one of the best relationships out of the
show totally so I think it's not I think
it's a recipe for success I just think
what is concerning is that can't really
read colton yet and paradise really
ruined him it's just like a lot of
colton in such a short amount of time
because it's gonna be directly on Becca
season where he was very tolerable and a
catch to paradise where I literally
found his presence irritating and now
it's like even more and it's like it's
like it's enough I don't think we did
anything wrong on paradise he was the
only thing he was a victim love was
overexposure he did everything right he
was honest with Tia about his feelings
to a fault like any other guy would have
just taken her rose and kept going and
then broken up with her after the show
like he really wore his heart on his
sleeve and like I don't think he did
anything wrong the only thing about him
really that raises a red flag for me out
of everything is Aly Raisman situation
him saying he never brought a girl home
when Ali race man is there in a onesie
and nastya coming on this show and like
not being into cold what did she say we
were like you know Colton and also Shawn
Johnson's husband set up Ali and Colton
because they were on an NFL team sounds
familiar my dementia member like McNally
Grayson was like at the top of the world
under when made a video asking her out
on a date and she wound up going up
because he was teammates with Shawn
Johnson's now and she wound up going on
the date and they wound up dating for a
while and it was really cute uh-huh
but Nasia like wasn't into him no I
think Shawn regrets setting him up also
that's just a li race Minh is like a
species of human being that's like above
anyone on this planet she's not gonna
like there's nobody good enough for her
I agree she's just like right her and
Joe Jack Malina are perfect for each
other
and I'm sure maybe Colton no I didn't
tell you that it's definitely any
different I don't think Aly Raisman
motiva can you google it yeah no it's
just like it's a lot of Colton in such a
short amount of time and that's the one
thing I'm struggling with but this is
getting me excited like I haven't been
excited to watch a bad shirt since like
Rachael Lindsey season yeah like I I
have a newly reinvigorated interest
because like I like really the last time
it I I was excited to watch was Rachael
Lindsay because a it was a historic
moment be we love her chillin see we
fell in love with her and her shorts in
New Orleans and see it was just like a
great time to be alive but ever since
then I just have like literally no
interest definitely and I just want you
guys to all know like they they
sometimes they go into the depths of the
earth to find a Bachelor and they and
they don't rule out any option so Nick
vile could have been our bachelor so
let's just be glad yeah that is where
does this national outrage when Nick
vile like this is not a worthy cause to
be outraged about like at the end of the
day he's a nice guy who really didn't do
anything wrong in number four it's like
a little annoying okay fine I'll give
you that and he doesn't have a neck but
like what is with this outrage like
let's reserve this outrage for so many
other things like but the Nick pile of
it all I completely remember the world
being dis up in arms when Nick vile was
named bachelor I don't know just us and
so you know what you guys weren't there
for us and now we're gonna gonna be
there for you and see where you're out
you know I'm just like this is this is
the thing it's like bachelor production
conditioned us to hate Colton and then
it's now shoving Colton down our throats
it's like so I've said this before and
I've said this I am so firmly against
believing what Bachelor producers want
me to believe they wanted us to hate
Jordan I don't mind him he's a nice guy
he's like a little weird whatever they
want us to hate Chris
crystal I'm here for her they wanted us
to eat
Arion Lauren no I'm in love with them
they're the most real couple ever they
have a [ __ ] wedding date they're
getting art are you like they are real
like I'm sorry I just like I'm done
listening to what my place wants me to
feel do you know what I mean no I
totally agree and it's like they want me
to like certain people and it's like why
don't you show that Chris I was just
gonna say huh
they want us to like Chris they want to
select Eddie from friends Chandler's
roommate who likes to drive fruit on the
stone and he's an animal and the way
that he spoke about the women and
cheated on Tia and spoke about even
crystal before they started dating like
where's the outrage on that you guys
you're you're focused on all the wrong
things get your priorities in order
I couldn't agree more why are you
smiling like that Margot oh you were
right so Ali raised me my book about
Colton oh my girl you're not wearing a
mic sorry start again hi sorry it's me
sure our homage ham she wrote her book
in her book about when she was with
Colton and she went to visit him and she
said quote on quote unquote he said you
haven't done anything today so we're
gonna listen this sports radio station
and want to hear everything that they
have to say about me i sat silently for
the rest of the car ride I couldn't wait
to get out I felt embarrassed but also
angry that I traveled to see someone who
treated me so disrespectfully say it
again a little bit slower what exactly
did you say then I haven't done anything
today I want to listen to what this
sports radio show has to say about me
what does one thing have to do with the
other I think also if they're competing
I'm like who has accomplished more in
their careers like lol okay sports radio
stations gonna be talking about Allie
Ray's menthols oh yeah probably more
yeah I don't know I just that story
doesn't I don't understand it you know
that that's a weird special anecdotal
it's an excerpt so like if in their
whole relationship that's the word like
I know everything and relationships have
to be taken with a grain of salt like
you're always gonna like me about your
ex because it didn't work out and once
you're in a relationship like you can
say things and like not that any like
being mean to someone is correct but
like I've said some really [ __ ] mean
things to bed like know if you last
night I unplugged the modem while he was
doing his draftkings oh my god
I was on the phone with spectrum I'm
like slaving sweating trying to get this
house together
well he's [ __ ] doing its draft with
Zach and I'm like are you for real like
yeah and so I have to unplug it for two
seconds like put on a hot spot like and
I just went off and like you know that's
just me you took one of those sentences
out of context it's not good it doesn't
look at I'm not gonna lie no yeah no I
love Olivia Zach were there and then
they were like holy [ __ ] relax but it
was just like I'm I was sweating so much
yes Lading over my new home and he's
like in the corner playing games I
understand
um I think poets spectrum I want to say
two other things now Colton that proved
to me that he's like not the worst guy
ever first of all when they're sitting
around with the guys and the group's and
they're having those guy chats talking
forcing them to talk about cheese like
Colton is like in with the guys like
they like him he's cool and his closest
friend on Paradise seem to be Kevin who
is the coolest guy of all time and I'm
in love with him and to any friend like
whoever Kevin chooses to be friends with
is good and my heaven is the moral
compass so whoever he gravitates towards
we do as well and Colton and her talk
[ __ ] about the other guys on the show he
never got in fights with the other guys
on the show like he stayed above the
drama people seem to like him the guys
seem to like him I think they'd be on a
really likes him she gave him in her
final girl will get all the scoop from
boobs right so he's good in my book and
I'm excited about this new me too and
everyone needs to come down everyone
needs to seriously calm the [ __ ] down
and that you need to get your
application in because like it's not
only next week the deadline is coming up
it's not gonna happen guys why they
would chew me up and spit me out I know
they would it was a cute to say thank
you in a good way
perfect for the bachelor yeah yeah yeah
they love a big-breasted didn't you
wanna rush it in paradise yeah I would
go so I can honestly the only thing that
wouldn't you Bo don't crush in paradise
is the hair cuz you've so much hair no
idea the bun the bun yeah yeah yeah also
I just want to say shout out to Tia
because like when she was leaving
paradise it was like you could they
clearly had been on the beach for like
12 hours her hair is in a bun she gets
in the car in her bathing suit which is
hilarious yeah in her bun and like
absolutely no makeup and she is so
pretty and so confident like she didn't
even care and I just think that's so
cool
it's just so funny because every time
there's a bachelor who comes from the
season before on The Bachelorette they
like can't stop talking about the
Bachelorette I don't think Colton's
gonna be talking about back at the whole
season he's gonna be talking about Tia I
think he'll be talking about both
because he came into paradise like still
so hung up yeah Becca like I Billy was
not here for her the selection but like
now I really like her I really like so
skidding she's like made a great life
for herself she seems so happy
ya know that's what I love when like
people hate the bachelor and
bachelorette but then like they couldn't
care less because they're so happy Peter
I mean uh Brian and Rachel like everyone
the way they were it made it seem was
that Rachel took a consolation prize and
that Peter was like the man who was the
one that got away and like she couldn't
have cared less I was so far from the
truth and they are so happy and like
they're really getting married and Jojo
and Jordan yeah and that happiness is
like infectious and you can't help but
be happy for them so I'm so here for
Becca and Garrett also before we move on
because we must I I need to make an
announcement because I was told
explicitly to announce that Lauren
Bushnell is not to evening that guy oh
yeah she texts me cuz she saw the video
on the toes so he was just like a fun
cry attack it she's gonna music final
secret video girl kami Mendes everyone's
doing it that is like surgery a fun
thing and they like filmed it in the
Bahamas it looks like they were all
having fun she said I was on vacation
with all my friends like the Fergie
twins were there they're having the best
time and I just think she she's like a
beautiful blonde girl I'm sure he didn't
have to pay her I think loves country
they're hip they're really good friends
it is a dream they're not too good for
her okay I want her to date Brett
Eldredge okay so me and Margo have been
trying to set her up with Brett Eldredge
like we don't really know him Becca till
he knows him so like I told her to ask
Becca Becca Tilly um but I said like now
that you're in like the country scene
like you're one step closer to Brett
Eldredge and she's fully on board oh
thank god Wow that would be amazing
also still down for her and Ben Higgins
to get back together meet you if that
door is still oh it's not but meet you
it's definitely not no like not at all
but I'm done me too okay next story and
just like the greatest news of all time
Vanderpump rules lila ken is engaged to
her boyfriend Randall Emmett and they
are so [ __ ] cute and legitimate and
they took a trip to Vegas afterwards
which is just like they're so rich they
were in Cabo when they got engaged and
like looking so happy and fierce and
like in people fireworks and like
everything was just like her ring is
absolutely enormous
not my style at all but beautiful memo s
it's I've never seen that ring like it
yeah it's weird with the halo yeah it's
not me I like it for her and like she
can really do ab no wrong wrong and then
they went to Vegas to party
with the Vanderpump rules crew well who
was there Tommy Katie were there Jackson
Britney were there Tom Sanibel was there
I don't believe Ariana was there yeah
people are like saying stuff yeah well
we'll see we'll see it all unfold but
like honestly the dynamic is so shifted
now that like it's kind of weird yeah
also I I don't know if they're still
filming the season cuz usually they rap
in August but I hope that they have this
like me too
her trajectory of going from like a
mistress side piece hosting cheater she
went on the yacht she was a yacht girl
yeah to having her boyfriend and his his
marriage which like that never happens
for the side piece and then getting him
to propose to her it's like they are so
legitimate and I'm so happy for I'm so
happy for I loved her when we met her
she literally couldn't have been a nicer
more like empathetic cool human being I
just think that like this is all so
weird now because to be honest like they
were except with the exception of she
and I like they were all like so mean to
her in the beginning and they did not
give her a chance I'm like now they're
all like thirsty for her and like I'm
taking the jet to Vegas and it's just
like remember Jax like really tried to
hook up with her even when he was dating
Brittany and then he lied and made her
look crazy and they all took Jax aside
I'm like now Jax is taking her
boyfriend's plane home for Vegas like
the dynamic for me is too weird and too
fake I mean that's the show that like I
didn't slept it's not her best friend
but I lost seems to be like so a look
above it in a sense that like she
doesn't care about any of the [ __ ] like
she really is like like she knows who's
there for her and that's why she was
like been friends with James for so long
and even though he was like such a
[ __ ] to her but now she's like done
with him
but like she really cares more about
like the loyalty and the friendship then
like the then the other girls who just
care about the show yeah but I think she
also recognizes that it's a show so like
if someone's talking [ __ ] about her I
don't think that that's like a cardinal
sin for her because that's like the
nature of the show ya know I just it's
weird like the dynamic is weird also
like Randall Emmett who like hangs out
with Martin Scorsese like oh no club
with Thomson of all is weird but Martin
Scorsese is watching Hannah Burrell so
it all comes full circle it's like her
time on the show was really running out
because you can only be like a status of
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills while
on Vanderpump rules for so long it's the
same for a lot of the other cast members
like Stassi is so successful and to
pretend like she's just like trying to
get a job being Lisa's party planner
like they need to
yesBut la la this is another level this
is not Stassi yes but it
a problem with the show yeah this
chassis thing like makes no sense she's
not a party planner her podcast is so
successful
she's an influencer she's a revolved
girl she's fine right she could just
like sit on her butt and record podcasts
and like live the life Riley
but like allow us like this may break
the mold
now this lawa thing and it will I'm so
excited to see where it goes and I'm
just so happy first she's had a rough
year no she's not even rough here she's
had a rough like time on the show she's
yeah but it's all paid off like and
that's why I feel like it was you're
just a good cool person like every
everything like comes to light I don't
agree more also my god my brain is like
really oh this just and I feel like this
is now becoming a popular theory and I
think it's really important that
everyone knows that I came up with it
because like now everyone's saying it
but like I've said at the Reunion
they're like she really is that gonna
elevate into a housewife of Beverly
Hills and this just even furthers that
and now everyone's saying it but I think
it's important that you know that I came
up with that theory like a couple months
ago I think they'll squeeze out her time
on Vanderpump rules like until she
definitely until she gets married but
then after that I think we have at least
one one or two more years with her yeah
you're like her being a tin can at like
the Gotti whatever with John Travolta
like she is no waitress you know no oh
my god I'm I'm so so happy for each I'm
the number one fan look so happy yes her
brown hair brown hair you know I'd like
the blonde better this is a different
look but I she can do a run I want I'm
excited to see how it looks on the show
because she always looks amazing yeah
anyways just great news okay
they said story I only found out about
last night from the snip oh my god I see
your iPad is it the Trader Joe's thing
it's the Trader Joe's kind I'm so upset
about it Cosby Show actor response to
Tyler Perry's job offer
so the phone has been ringing off the
hook for actor Jeffrey Owens since he
was publicly shamed for working at
Trader Joe's quote it's been non-stop
contact emails and phone calls and texts
and interviews Owens 57 explained on
Wednesday and a follow-up interview with
Good Morning America let's serve from
the beginning yeah so his paychecks it's
not doing a good job a photo went viral
of what's his name uh Jeffrey Owens
who's had a pivotal role as one of the
older kids on The Cosby Show he a
picture went viral of him he now works
at Trader Joe's and he was bagging
groceries for someone and someone took a
picture of it and liked it
viral that like making fun of him for
like once being on a famous show and now
like working a real job job shaming him
job shaming him and like it went so
viral and then in a negative way but it
immediately took a turn where like
everyone was praising him for being like
a true artist like and that's what Tyler
Perry said Tyler Tyler Perry's response
was so true he's like that's the
tell-tale sign of like a true art it's
like you're not always gonna be making
money doing what you love so you have to
hustle on the side and then Tyler Perry
offered him a job and this guy got to go
on GMA he said literally everyone has
been calling me but he's like I don't
want to get work that way like I want
someone to please like I'm happy to get
an audition from this process like I
don't want to get a job as an actor just
because like everyone feels bad for me
now but they've seen his acting
obviously uh
Tyler Perry said quote I have tremendous
respect for a man who has no pride about
working he's going to do what he has to
do to support his family Perry said I
know a lot of people that refused to go
to work when they're between acting gigs
when I saw that I was moved by him
that's the true measure of a man the
true measure of an artist I had so much
respect for him me too that was like the
perfect response I didn't even know like
how I felt until Tyler Perry said it for
me right and I think what people are
neglecting to remember is that like
Cosby Show used to rerun and they would
get those royalties all the time and now
that Bill Cosby ruined it for everyone
oh I didn't even think of that there's
there don't air Cosby show up anymore so
like you need that to supplement that
occasion no syndication oh my gosh I
didn't even think of that
right so it's obviously it's Bill
Cosby's fault all of this is by the way
at the end of the day you know matter
what your problem is it's somehow it's
either a Bill Cosby's fault or the Bill
DeBlasio spot or everyone see oh yeah
yeah no by the way it's so like when
this story came out at first I've been
following I was like so upset I'm like
our generation is disgusting like I
really first of all Trader Joe's is an
amazing place like it's just wonderful
it has great snacks it's like having a
job there it's like a very nice job it's
like it's a very clean place they have
air conditioning like it's a great
respectable job so like when it was
about any form of work expect a totally
like there's no like job I think that
job shaming even looks like kind of a it
sounds like you talk when we say it like
that could it be a real thing it's like
only in Tennessee so vile and to like
[ __ ] on the way that someone is
supported to their family returning a
living and totally an honest living
no totally like what just because you
once worked as a job as an actor like
you have to do that forever like
sometimes it's hard where's Ganz
right yeah and see justice for Yancey
from sleepover who never had another job
in her life
there's so many people out there who
like acted and now they don't it's not a
big deal it's not a big deal and I'm
glad that all of this happened so that
Jeffrey Owens gets the shine that he
deserves yeah and I was like so Cuban he
was like me in my way for reading the
tweets like we were so shocked like
because it really took a turn quickly it
went viral for like a second in a
negative way and then people are like
wait this is really [ __ ] up and then
it's just started being like praising
him so like it's just like it's like so
sad like imagine just like going viral
for like having a job I can't and the
chant and I love Tyler Perry being a
hero we needed and this guy's so humble
he's like I'm not gonna take a job
because like people think I like I'm sad
about working at Trader Joe's he's like
I have to provide I love everything
about this guy no michi we got him on
the chest I know he was on GMA recently
but maybe he can make it maybe he can
make it to the big time I saw last night
when I was watching The Bachelor that
GMA has a new daytime program GMA day
they're really trying hard to it's
Michael Strahan and a bond oh yeah
they're trying super hard to compete
with today's show and like they never
will
but the one thing that habits the
bachelor because they always get yeah
Michael Strahan
yeah great at his job and Kelly Ripa's
good too but she's not Good Morning
America I'm talking my GMA like Robin
Wright and the George Stephanopoulos
look-alike I forgot his name it's not
it's not working for me no no maybe they
need uh she just won our show at 10:30
just to you know glam it up just to
shake it up Chicago yeah okay next story
that shook the world Kim Kardashian
shuts down rumors of her affair with
Drake quote never happened
end of story there was this crazy
investigative Twitter thread picked up
steam over the weekend and intent to
once again connect the dots between
Drake's subliminal hints that he's been
romantically involved with Kim
Kardashian in the past Kim had enough of
the noise and quickly shut down the
rumors of an affair with the six got on
Monday
Nick Cannon appeared as a guest for an
episode of complexes every day Charcot
last week where he described the theory
of Drake and his ex-girlfriend Kim
Kardashian having sexual relations as
quote ex-girlfriend mccannon unclear
those were their billboards new grammar
quote isn't a far-fetched thought the
shade room picked up cannons thoughts
and Kim K hopped into the comments
section to
swiftly defuse the spreading tabloid
fodder and that everyone know that
nothing allegedly happened between her
and Drizzy quote never happened end of
story she abruptly wrote on Instagram
so there's a whole Twitter thread that
really goes in depth into the lyrics and
makes it makes a strong case well it was
all really weird cuz it's like who's
Kiki and like there's ember yeah the
only person who's ever publicly been
called Kiki like is Kim you see T Palmer
and it's not Kiki Palmer
honestly I wanted to be keke palmer i
love her so much and i only want the
best most amazing things for her in her
career you have to look at her instagram
because she did her own in my feelings
but yeah because she's of course wishes
he gave and she makes these videos that
are so funny you would love that so
multi-talented she's an amazing singer
dancer and she's hilarious I love her I
don't love her
but anyways back to the kiki of it all
kim kardashian is Kiki like she's aunt
Kiki right she's Keeks
she's - no that's for sure that would be
like if Drake had a song called smee chi
like da about are you riding say you'll
never remember cinch cuz just energy and
I want you know it's high saturation
concert this weekend by the way I'm not
a big Drake like fan music wise but that
stage that stage was so cool it was
really good he had these girls who
danced in a few songs and like I wish
they were out there the whole time like
they were such good dancers and it was
all like they were all doing different
things it was like it was freestyle and
Brian I just yeah like I don't think
they learned a routine except a few
different things and I was just like
loving then yeah but he was great migos
came out French Montana came out oh yeah
he's like he did it for Brooklyn what we
heard a sheen of it all the Khloe
Kardashian of it all was asking like
having the time of his life yeah he
loves Drake but he doesn't want his new
stuff as much that's what he yes Drake
Zach's Bar Mitzvah theme knows Drake
wasn't around
oh but Zach's parents 14 let's get the
movies Oh what I think it was hip hop
because it would be yeah cuz he's like
so he loves it all that was hip hop
maybe at the movies he doesn't love this
this era album but it was a great show
we have with Kristen Pete we had such a
low you did yeah cuz I saw Christmas air
- that's so cute next to each other
thanks to him bite mmm
oh you ever was gone it was Friday
anyways so they she's saying never
happened in the way that she went about
it like just
and sure that makes me believe her right
because if it was sure she would ignore
that but the signs like they're just so
crazy and it's like if you look at so
many lyrics it's like it's so obvious
and then the fact that Drake never
responded to push it cheese dish track
because what he would have said about
Kanye would have been unforgivable is
what people are saying again but yes
that the the thread had so many so much
evidence but I read a thread over the
weekend that had so much evidence that
like when I started reading I'm like
this is so dumb and then by the end I
was like oh my god Lady Gaga had this
girl killed but like she didn't you know
what I mean
so it's people on the internet are just
so creative that like the theory
probably sounded like it had a lot of
Robbie tossed behind it but it wasn't
true do you know what I mean this lady
Gaga one is wild but like I could see
Kim and Drake together no meet you and
it's like crazier [ __ ] happens in
Hollywood every day where it's like
non-consensual sex like the two of them
together sex they live down the street
and it's like you know everyone in
Hollywood is like there's no laws for
that like maybe the rules of marriage
you don't apply all the time maybe but
it's like the public would never
understand that so Kimberly Kim can't
explain it okay
yeah but like right did happen like I
don't think that's so crazy and like I'm
sure Kanye in you and yes you are the
world he watched or because you know
what they say that Kanye yes no nope
it's like Kim allows Kanye to do stuff
and Connie on ask him to do stuff so
it's really not so crazy what do you
empty say about it has he said anything
about the Drake thing about Drake and
Kim no I haven't seen anything hmm
auntie Anderson he's been busy launching
his own podcast it's 11:11 make a wish
okay next story before I decide if we're
gonna do a sixth one mm-hm
Amazon choice Amazon joints Apple in the
one trillion dollar club oh mama son
briefly joined the one trillion dollar
club on Tuesday becoming the second US
company to reach the milestone milestone
market cap in as many months the
e-commerce giant saw shares rise to two
thousand fifty dollars and fifty cents
just before noon putting its valuation
just about a hundred billion dollars
behind Apple which crossed the line a
little over a month ago as the morning
to us reported that may sound like a
huge
some separating the two but Amazon could
actually surpass the iPhone maker in the
short order the stock 74% gain this year
is more than double that of Apple and it
shares that both companies keep the same
pace Amazon could close the gap by the
end of the year well here's the thing
what the article fails to mention is
that the reason they passed the trillion
dollar line so quickly is because I
moved and I had been ordering literally
everything from Amazon and it's coming
the next day and they find it really
shocking that the first company in
America to reach the trillion dollar
mark was Apple like I really thought it
would have been Amazon really yeah I
feel like has been major and
successfully major for longer like
Amazon really didn't start taking over
the world until like two years ago
yeah three ish years ago cuz remember
when they were just books like when I
was in college like Amazon you just
thought of his books like but I knew
that they like had a partnership with
Sephora and like Karmaloop and I could
buy clothes and makeup but I could
always just say up from the credit card
scene and like it was books yeah so I'll
always have that College benchmark and
it wasn't till after I graduated that
they're like Whole Foods Alexa listening
government I'm talking about just like
when we were in camp like if you needed
anything you would like get on your back
berry and order it like sunscreen from
Amazon it would come in two days we
would order from Amazon because we could
pass it off as something more legit no
because it was the best place for it and
had the two day shipping I don't think
everyone was ordering for Madison but
now with like the prime era mm-hmm it's
a whole nother world out there no just
like when you think of all the facets of
Amazon's business it's really quite
startling cuz you have Amazon you have
prime pantry you have Prime video you
have the Whole Foods of it all you have
no Kindle you Alexa Alexa echo firestick
like there's just so many like there's
so many divisions the original content
transparency right right we're right at
handmade shell yeah totally so good for
them but it wasn't always that ways what
I'm trying to say and I feel like we
were really early on the animal worry
because we were just early adaptors to
online shopping in general yeah like it
really is a really caters to our needs
um but I'm happy for them and they you
know what I realized
like when you don't know what you say
you always happy for that or like but
you know yeah I'm really happy first so
it's okay that's how you like end yeah
but then I was gonna say it's
well-earned henna and I'm looking
forward to the next American company to
hit the one trillion dollar were just
like so afraid of Amazon they're like
it's taking over the world and I'm like
yeah it's taking over the world
I [ __ ] love Amazon it makes my legs
tail goddamn easy and like
someone's gonna take over the world and
if it's Amazon I think we'll all live
right like people are afraid of Amazon
like yes it is said that the mom-and-pop
drugstores are going out of business but
like as a consumer I'm like great
everything's cheaper now and comes
faster like what could be better
oh and come straight to your door right
and they can have a drone delivery in
the bedroom the mom-and-pop drug store
so don't even have what you need anymore
no and I just heard about the craziest
sort Ponzi scheme going on at a
mom-and-pop drug store on that breezy
side really yeah and I roamed the aisles
at CVS looking for what I need for so
long because the organ in front of you
no sense and no one works there and then
I have to use one of those South
checkout machines that is literally
gonna land me in a mental institution
I stole unintentionally a heating pad
from a CVS with one of those when I was
in college it was a CVS right across
from my dorm and it only [ __ ] had the
self checkouts and I was so sick and I
bought so much and like I was on a
college budget so like I was buying all
the [ __ ] and then I was like okay damn I
was too much money in the heating pad
was $40 so I took it out but I forgot to
take it out of the bag it just like took
it off the machine and when I got home
I'm like oh my god I did not pay for
this and like this was back when I was
still a good person so I brought it back
and there was like one person who worked
there and he like couldn't he was so
confused I couldn't believe that I was
like bringing back stolen merchandise he
was like what I'm like I didn't pay for
this they're like where'd you get it I'm
like it was in my house and they just
they couldn't the whole concept was like
lost on that well I punched a CVS
self-checkout machine this weekend I
there's nothing better than when Jackie
gets like a little I guys it's so rare
that's first I was like and then I
literally punch this or palm uh I might
have been palm I don't think I made a
fist but I literally was like and then I
was like it was really crazy I had that
yeah I literally like blacked out
because what happened was like you have
to put all of your items like on this
neato little shelf so they can feel that
you put the item in the bag and it's
like I was having toilet paper and paper
towels like how the [ __ ] that supposed
to fit so I was holding the top but
every time you ate every time I breathed
my finger might go up or something and
it was like going back and back and back
and the woman's there's like she has
talking about the machine like there's a
person there who's talking about the
machine she won't help you but she was
like China but she's like she's got a
mind of her own the machine I'm like so
do you can someone to check me out
the machine just kept not like it kept I
was at checkout and then it would go
back please place your item and I was
like and I just pawned it and it's like
I just want to get in front of the story
because in case of video ever gets out
do you ever think about like
surveillance videos getting out about
you because I have one instance where
like if it ever gets out I don't even
want to say it cuz like someone will go
look for it now you know like this would
be that instance I'm getting in front of
it and I want you guys to know like they
drove me to insanity one of one of the
times we're in Atlantic City like we got
back to the room like literally at 7:00
in the morning like wasted I don't know
if you were there you were probably
there me and Ben were walking to our
room like I never do this but like I was
so drunk I just like lifted up my shirt
and and it was so crazy I'm like oh my
god I was like Ben was like you're crazy
but like it was like no one was there so
I can nobody signed it was like my
husband but like then I'm like security
and now like every couple months like
I'll wake up at night and be like just
like someone now TMZ is on the lookout
and they're also going to my local CVS
like it was a dark moment for me and I
and I literally had to go back to that
CVS not the next morning to get eggs and
I was like they're burying my head and
she went embarrass Auto I was
embarrassed at oh but when I went there
the night before like I was made up and
looking gone and when I went through
next morning it looked like terrible so
they probably thought I was a different
person
okay good truly well I used to live on
top of a Trader Joe's a CVS no I used to
live on top of a Trader Joe's but yeah I
don't know why we're talking about that
we owe it has The Cosby Show do you mean
I just had like a delayed thought like
yeah thinking that when you ever talk
about the Trader Joe's saying but
whatever and just like one more little
tidbit a sixth story just to like but to
Bibiana has a flight so we have to go oh
[ __ ] um just like Noah Cyrus and Lil's
hands very public breakup and the
Charlie puth of it all
so they've been like pretty screenshots
on her Instagram story it's like
breaking up like they haven't spoken to
each other I don't think in like a week
via one of them that's the future no and
like there was this meme that they sent
of Charlie puth that was like in the
text conversation I like him being a
porn star it was so funny I just think
that that relationship was doomed from
the start I don't know then
like I don't care to know them but I
just really appreciate seeing Charlie
puth involved and what has he spoken
about it at all I don't think so um okay
so we're gonna break for two three
minutes we're gonna go grab baby on if
you have any questions for her I'm
watching on Facebook Jackie's watching
on YouTube about paradise about Colton
about anything about her chain roller
just let us know drop a question for BB
Jules we will be back in a minute so is
stay tuned
you
we are back with the one named wonder
Madonna herself Viviana you are one name
wonder what is your last name Julian
Julian I need yours yeah your first see
last day yeah very intuitive first no
first lassie is someone who you have to
say their last name with their first
thing she said obviously you and I just
suggest one name wonder you and I
disagree on this because our first C
last E is also someone whose first name
and last name are both like names like
Barry David they're both like first
names he's also first you guys because
you have to say both that's true
his whole family welcome to the toast
situated from Mexico this is seriously
good dreams come true this has been a
long time coming because this is the
greatest that was so drunk and I don't
remember but you remember that I
accidentally stepped on that woman's
foot and she happened to have been like
the head of something for a tea and like
she was like throwing a party that we
were at and she like literally cornered
me in the bathroom yes I remember that
was really scary but she's so sweet yeah
oh you know her I'm sorry it was really
an accident
her name is Karen she's that Karen so
started - Queen yeah she's all about
this world is she Digital Creator she
was like tooth all about everything and
anything like okay I'm really sorry I
was super drunk and I stepped on her
foot I like I can imagine that someone
like me stepping on someone's foot hurts
so I'm really sorry Karen we are so
happy to have you here we have so many
questions for you and we just have to
jump right in we just have to from the
beginning okay you were on re-season and
you just did not get like justice was
never served for you ever really still
makes me upset that you set up that date
for him and then he took it with morin
and did he Lauren not just Lauren like
Becca like everybody in the house went
on this date but
meals are evolving today everything now
that you set it up I don't know if he
did I mean I watched it on the show yeah
it was just like okay but you know it's
so hard to pay attention to all these
women and you know I really wanted to
make a like all these girls are getting
really creative with like what they were
doing for him that's like okay well
maybe I need to do something work I'm a
little bit more comfortable where I can
talk to him because every every time I
went to talk to him it was in this space
where like anyone can come in and
interrupt right
what if I do something more private or
cute then I can then epic fail it was so
funny yeah I was like at this point it's
like I've tried way too much right now I
feel like this dude doesn't like me and
it's not gonna work out that was so
funny and so sad and like I'm really I I
was upset for you but I really am a big
fan of Lauren and Arie and so I'm really
like I'm not happy it didn't work out
between you two what are your thoughts
on them because the whole world hates
them I always thought it was gonna be
Lauren because the previous day where we
had the wrestling match
like Lauren interrupted me and she spoke
to him twice you know that she was like
really nervous and he just had like I'm
big on energy like his energy shifted
completely one who saw her was like he
was stripped to the core and then with
this whole date thing you can tell he
was really trying to take more time with
her to speak because he said can I have
five more minute and so when Becca was
announced as you know like Ari's choice
I obviously everybody loves better right
but I was a little bit shocked that it
wasn't Lauren and then it all comes
around full circle right so cute
together they're so happy and she would
think that like I'm a hater and stuff
really that's when he's about yeah the
show is about finding your wife yeah I
have gone through some struggles but he
found his wife did Becca right because
then she got to be the Bachelorette and
if you know two more weird and broken up
with her she wouldn't have had time to
become the bachelor no no he did right
there and now she's so happy so it all
worked out the way it was supposed to
and then he went on paradise which is
where you were meant to be mm-hmm tell
me about the paradise logistics because
we always say like it looks like a good
time but like the heat and the hair and
the makeup
it's brutal it is right brutal so like
walking around the city yesterday I was
like I feel like I'm back in paradise
really what in the world is that like
men have a breeze and yeah by the ocean
but it's that humid it's that hot I gave
up on Mike's like what am I gonna do my
makeup for totally you also like are
such a natural beauty no and I'm
obsessed with your looking at you too
different from something like the girls
on the shower I'll look this all
beautiful they all kind of look the same
and like have this really like contour
like just everything and I just feel
like you bring such a different brush
and I feel like you just arrived
paradise yes yet and this really
bothered me there were like really not a
lot of eligible guys there I wouldn't I
get along with all the guys so I
wouldn't say that there wasn't I just
you know I've had my series like why do
you sign up to the show because I have
years of bad relationships right and
like not believe me my exes but just you
know things don't work out and so you go
on to this whole thing where you think
that these guys are gonna be really
serious yeah you know there are
relationships that come out of that and
are really successful from Paradise but
it's like three out of the ten most not
everyone's there and the wife
I just wasn't one of the people that got
noticed year right that's true when you
went into paradise like who were you
hoping to me so it's a little bit weird
for me to say this now because I'm kind
of like friends with these guys and so
once you get to know them get to know
them you don't like anymore well I mean
it's not that I don't like him it's just
like you know you want to tread lightly
yeah whatever so like I think Jason and
Paradise would have really changed the
game of the dynamic a green entirely
because Patti walked in nobody would
have expected him and he's just like
Jason and he's like an eligible bachelor
yeah I need a man who wants a wife but
he was holding out for the role of the
watch right and dad bleep would have
been I would have oh yeah basically I'm
like a top-three girl yeah like
everybody's like what's your type and
I'm like I'm just in a role with the top
three it was important three girls
that's what I am and also it's like
Becca weeded them out for you and here
are the best guys exactly was there
someone today ask you before you go on
like who you're into they do especially
for the people that are like coming in
later
yeah right so they yeah they definitely
can probably just I'm I'm like an open
book and I always want to approach
things like not just fixed on looks or
any yeah because I've had really good
relationships from guys I'm like it'll
don't touch me and then I'm like yeah oh
my gosh I really love you yeah that's so
true yes in paradise but then it seems
like none of the guys you really wanted
to meet were there yeah so I mean we can
like somebody peps like a few of them or
like oh you're closed off and it's like
okay no I take this seriously like I
don't want a boyfriend just to have a
boyfriend like I don't need like you
come out of a relationship in this and
you get like a thousand more followers
and everybody else usually I don't
really need to
the relationship like I really want this
to be for me or someone that I can spend
my time with and just because I'm not
vibing out with you within the first
three days and straddling and making out
with you like hello work for the good
guys are a little lazy like okay I'm
closed off like if you really liked me
you wouldn't yeah because the schola
conditions them just to think that like
within six hours you can fall in love
with someone and they can travel you I
mean I definitely would love that yeah
it's like not wasting my time the rest
of ya like it really happens with people
where it's just like they click and
they're like okay don't need to look at
anybody else yeah I was actually was
like with Jade and Tanner and Carly and
Evan the last few days because you know
the announcement oh yeah ma and they're
so cute and like that's real and when
you look at these guys who like real guy
yeah that were serious about being in
heavy job you know yeah I think like
there's a lot that goes on so like a
couple weeks ago when we were finally
gonna get the Tia and Colton saga to be
over and Colton was about to go home
because she I gave her rose to someone
else you saved him I did now I'm I think
I know the answer I just would like some
clarification do they make you do that
no no guys pay attention to everyone's
face in that whole scene like everyone
was shocked shocked and when you're
going into this rose ceremony you kind
of have an idea like who who's going to
pick who I was you know at this point I
hadn't made any connection with anyone
I liked everyone but I'm someone who's
just like when things go wrong for
people and you see how like every
everything around Colton was dramatic
nobody had a chance to talk to him you
know like everything was all this drama
the guys I felt bad for him I'm like
this guy just walked into paradise and
can't catch a break yeah I spoke to him
that day I'm like I just want to talk to
you because like I feel like I've been
hating on you and I don't know why I
hate you right now it was like America's
feeling that way too now so so we turn
it around we talked and I was like this
guy's such a good guy he needs a
freaking break and yeah that's why I did
that
interesting and then you also were the
the matchmaker who brought them back
together
just simplified it broke it down with
Department like you guys liked each
other give it a chance right so thank
you for that because when they were
happy it was really nice
yes so has Colton thanked you yet for
inadvertently making him The Bachelor I
literally Texan and I was like hey I
want 10% dad do you know how much I pay
him no I've always heard rumors but
nobody really knows how much they get
paid I feel like that the rumors it's
comparable to a year salary who has to
stop working and he's an NFL player so
like he was now oh maybe he's making $0
I think he's a great he's obviously the
like I call it the ultimate mic drop
because no but everybody knew that he
was a contender but like nobody really
thought that he was like that serious
and he's like you know how they did like
to tease you yes so annoying but
watching him yesterday was a yesterday I
feel like the date was so long
yeah dude you wake up so early to be on
that's like not like the total sorry
stroll in at 11:00
we do I would take that job I'm watching
those like he looks so good he's so
dreamy I just focus he's very
well-spoken he has all these really
great qualities his foundations go like
he has everything running and he's so
careful like whoa people don't realize
like look how cautious he is as a person
like you'll never hear dirt about him
yeah he's like except the Holly basement
thing that heard today but it's fine but
he's just like it like has all these
great qualities that you would want in a
husband like he has his real job he runs
his foundation isn't such a Merry Widow
just you know like now he just needs the
show is basically giving this guy who
hasn't had the opportunity to really
have a dating life home to date
yeah he's in a really good way but like
he deserves it I granted Blake and Jason
would have been great leads as well I
don't understand why America so mad
neither us either we just spent 20
minutes it's not that big of a deal he's
tall he's good-looking yeah dogs he's
rich
you know like you can have a baby in no
time yeah he's not Nick vile he
definitely doesn't have an STD because
he's he's clean yeah people don't know
how serious that is so in order to go on
paradise you have to pass says an STD
test right yeah do you know of anyone
who was asked to go on but didn't get to
go because they have me
and I and I and I don't think that we
would ever find that out obviously yeah
I think that they did like a really good
job being that you're on the show you
know that that person's like a clean
person it's just like you just have to
keep on with you know like that track
that you not mess it up like how
embarrassing is it that like oh that's
to get casted to be on the show when
then seven months later you get reached
and they reach out for paradise and
they're like what did you do in those
seven months who did you do in those
seven months actually that's so crazy
you don't want to be that person no not
at all so would you ever go back on
paradise or you're you're good I don't
know man I feel like I feel like I'm
fine I feel like you're not done though
that's true I don't feel like I'm done
but I do like think that like maybe
paired like unless I knew 1,000% these
guys were going that I could actually
really be interested in then I would put
myself in that like environment but I
feel like does Welles need another
bartender right yeah he's the best
scenario you would be a great bartender
you and Astrid should bartend just
giving life excited let you love it oh
my god we love her I'm obsessed with her
I mean I seriously called her and I was
like I'm starting to talk like you and
it's freaking me out so weird when you
hang out with people like when you go to
camp Paradise is like camp and your hang
out with people so much we start to talk
like them yeah she says like bugged out
so I started saying you're bugged out
and she's like you seem bugged out and I
was like every other word is bugged I
don't know what to do really obsessed
with Kevin Nash and I hope that they're
together watching this right now and I
was laying about that sign I couldn't
sleep and I was wondering like where are
they gonna live because he's from Canada
where does she live where she on Tampa
right now okay I think that she would
move oh yeah yeah yeah I think she
wanted to paradise like her lease was up
he packed up her stuff oh and she was
just like I'm ready to move somewhere
like literally that was the conversation
we were having before her and Kevin stop
writing it off so if things work out
great with them I'm not speaking for her
but the vibe that I get from their
relationship is as if like she would be
willing yeah
like the move if necessary and Kevin
said that last night on the show that
she'd been moved to Toronto and you know
what I guess we're going to Toronto I
guess you have the choices hittin the
road love you were just in LA and you
filmed after the final rose the reunion
super uehara nice reunion
what was that like
everybody needs to tune in is it a
chance
it's one it's torture and dramatic yes
so dramatic that it's just like oh my
gosh my eyes hurt really but it's
everybody talks about like the most
dramatic we've ever at the end I was
like you got to be kidding me like it
cannot get any worse than this it's so
crazy like I literally can't talk about
it but people are just like don't have
brains
oh and just really don't know how to
help themselves right like think about
your life for a second I think it's so
bad and I think the one off too so
everyone is there the majority of the
council see important people who's out
there yeah I don't remember they're
really unimportant yeah yeah maybe
people that like didn't last or
something yeah I feel like I saw
everyone and you were an re-season you
did not get along with cristal know how
Wayne it sounded I didn't get along I
was just like [ __ ] don't [ __ ] with me
she was and she's [ __ ] acres yeah she
was like she was a lot on re-season -
that was not the space for her well this
is the thing like everybody was pissed
off so if you are even you can already
tell that I'm someone like I'm a girl's
girl like you don't mess with my friends
like I will come at you right retching
Wiener style yeah um but she was just
really pissing people off and I told her
like don't be that girl like don't
everybody here just is trying to get by
and you're just being annoying and it's
you're being annoying yeah you're just
from straighter out yeah so but then
after we were perfectly fine right and I
got along in paradise yeah I'm paradise
it was kind of just like you know people
are gonna try to make it something that
it's not obviously we weren't into the
same guy and it was fine I was like dude
you're not a [ __ ] no she's like being
so normal
she is normal yeah it's just I mean this
show makes you crazy it does like I
thought I couldn't get any crazier right
so from the day you got there till the
day you left paradise how long was it I
wasn't there I think they filming is
like three weeks and so what I was later
like okay so with ten days though no
phone no TV no books no magazine I
generally don't even like I tried to
journal but like everything such a bland
laid blur that feels like it was longer
for sure it's like jail no and we're
it's like you were there for a month and
a half and then thought to try make it
seem like it every three days is a week
yeah well like I mean that's why when
people flip-flop so quickly and that's
the other thing like in my head I'm like
okay if I'm not heavily and like if I'm
like really not interested in these guys
like why am I gonna sit here make out
with them right what if my like mr.
great walks in and perfect totem then he
finds out that I've been like letting in
around like it was just gonna be like
wow you know like I would kind of feel
the same way if like I walked in and I
liked this guy and then I found out that
is maybe someone okay like how serious
are you
yeah I wanted to make sure like I really
like it's not like I'm desperate for a
boyfriend but I'm not gonna waste my
time no you're not desperate just to
make out with someone on TV that's why I
think like you could go back to paradise
cuz it's like you didn't even try to
make that tapping where it wasn't gonna
happen so it's like we just need a new
crop for you and we were talking about
this that's the problem with paradise
it's like it's so close to after the
Bachelorette that all the good guys are
hoping to be the bachelor so then they
don't go and then they come a year later
Eric they don't know what they rob days
they had a year of fame and ready who's
right and Robbie haze a year of fame and
like girls in their DMS and then they're
not serious anymore Yeah right it's a
problem I yeah I thought about but I do
really think that people like Jason or
Blake do paradise next year yeah I think
she's doing a paradise with his vampire
hair has to be sure I like his hair oh
my god no well when I met him in person
whose hair was shorter I feel like it
gives him like Robert De Niro vibe you
know I had a really mom like I like I'm
into like the guy that looks like a
badass like his hair like curls Ramseyer
loves I can't wait to yeah I mean you're
saying it's not a match
that you're just friends Jason cuz I
could J I'm you can see it I could see
it oh gosh no I've met him I've met him
and I like we're friends but you know he
was supposed to be the bachelor so it's
like he was holding out like do you you
know and I like being friends with
people and then whatever like if things
happen in the future then it happens but
you can't like be that fair so Michael I
mean this is a family yeah so you want
to make sure that like you you have like
good relationships with everyone and
you're not just like throwing out there
absolutely I just feel like as far as
having gone on the show going to
Paradise you'd have like an ideal
experience with games and winter games
oh gosh everybody keep I saw that people
kept asking about like Jordan yeah and I
just clarify there's like a lot of
things that weren't seen on winter games
like I was I never blindsided him I just
felt a lot of pressure because the last
relationship that I had been in the guy
we went 0 to 100 real quick and he was
also a foreigner and like all these
things that really scared me so too
similar and we had a horrible
relationship so it was like a lot of
like things that were really similar I
was like this isn't the kind of person I
know the kind sibility I need someone
that's like less wishy-washy someone who
knows like not saying anything about
about Jordan but at that point when I
saw him freaking out I was like I
freaked out so I can't be with someone
yes out and then I freaked out even more
so you know if you are looking for
someone with stability I would suggest
looking other places than The Bachelor I
think Ashley was like can we just like
you need to like you've given in a whole
year run like about dating Bachelor
people I was like okay before that I'm
all about the apps we've gotta look at
the most questions for you about your
skin because you're always Jade rolling
and I got a Jade roller because you have
one I copied it I love that I kept it in
my freezer right so I've been traveling
with mine and I haven't put it in the
fridge so I'm just like literally I open
my makeup that back today and I was like
I have it rolled
yeah what does it do I just like it
doesn't do anything doesn't stimulate
collagen but it just helps with like
deep puffing you know like your spoon
yes like that trick right and then like
you roll upwards and it's just really
good to just like help with your
circulation yeah and okay maybe it
doesn't do all this fancy stuff but it
feels great right does oh [ __ ] it's cold
I'm gonna have it hangover and then done
it it's like oh well because I have this
line in the middle of my forehead that
I'm gonna get Botox for soon but like
until then I roll it and sometimes it
gets smaller hmm I just got the [ __ ] out
of it well cuz you're stimulating
circulation like you it's just like
stimulation massages but what is your
skin routine like you haven't been
really I should say people complimenting
on my skin is huge because about like
three years ago maybe like tuna I don't
know a few years back I had to get on
accutane because apparently there's
adult acne yeah like that's a thing like
I never had acne when I was 13 and then
all of a sudden it was just crazy and I
went through a year it was like right
before my sister's wedding I went
through a year we're trying to figure it
out I think birth control is a double -
cuz
the hormones yeah so then my
dermatologist was like okay you've been
going out this for a year like my skin
got a little better for sometime and
she's like but at this point like let's
put you on accutane it was horrible it
tries to about like crazy drives you
like crazy like I only recommend to
people that like really feel like they
need it but then fortunately I have good
skin it's genetics to wear like scarring
I can scar but like eventually if I
sunblock like you're easy it'll heal so
I never got like the big like acne scars
right but I was always like some black
some buxom yeah oh that's so interesting
I use like this stuff it's all the stuff
that they sell in dermatologists just
because like medical grade stuff is just
like a little better better and then it
doesn't clog your pores it's like elta
MD super sheer sunblock and then I've
recently got into skin suta coals have
you guys heard about though yes oh my
gosh I just like went all out and got
like this like this it's like this
intensifier that helps with arms like
promotes allistic like it has two listed
I said anything that says promotes
collagen or helps like read anything
renewal I'm all about yeah yeah good to
know I'm Orioles actually we have two
questions some questions about logistics
is there a boom-boom room in paradise
like have these couples who are in love
like had sex I don't know because I left
before things got like really dirty yeah
honestly like it's three weeks and like
if you're with this person 24/7 it's the
equivalent of dating someone for six
months like I would want to sleep
together right together so like
something like they say well there's a
few boom-boom rooms and there's also
like AC in there so I would if I had a
boyfriend I'd be like we're sleeping
together
totally everyday right but and there's
no cameras in there I don't think there
is yeah yeah that's incredible and then
the other question that we had is so the
girls we see are doing their makeup
outside oh my god this is like a form of
torture okay because the room is outside
like it's an open area like there
everything's open so like your rooms are
open there's like a huge balcony so
literally like the dressings
part it's like at the part of the patio
of the terrace look you could see it
shouldn't do my makeup I'm like I can't
do this anymore no I might not do this
it's everything clearly only do my
makeup for Rose ceremonies I mean I was
only there twice I don't know what I
would have looked like at the end of it
Astrid literally said I look like the
naked mole rat from kim possible by the
end of yeah the season no she look like
the naked mole rat he has so much Aaron
and Raven unless he's and all I could
think about it's like my thick hair like
how do they survive I would have to get
a bob before going yeah you're poised
for success yeah well this was I have
curly hair so there's like the first
rose ceremony I was like what is that
frizz crap on my head like someone help
get her scrunchie put your hair up
that's why the last night rose ceremony
I was like at least my hair looks good
like slicked back
do you watch every episode live no well
yeah but then like now like I've been
here so it's like you know when I was
like I hung out with my friend the other
day yesterday it's like to have your
friend like sit down let's watch two
hours in there dice I will catch up like
on the plane ride home with you I need
to know what's going good yeah you know
like my friends like if I text them I
want to know the deal but I'm like I
don't know what happened I can't wait or
it's like how they're spinning it Lappe
as hell really yeah you can tell by
everyone's outfits they're putting days
like it's so great I guess it's like so
you know how things happen right and
like watching it back like you know you
know the deal yeah like it doesn't you
don't really catch all that stuff that's
so true like you know it's like we know
that you like we know what just happens
yeah that's fine but like I seriously
called Astrid right before good I was
like how bad were the episodes last
night she was like well I feel like last
night was like nothing crazy happened
Kevin and I said some funny stuff and I
was like I need to know what if they ask
me something
she's like basically it's like a filler
episode because like all the drama
happen on Monday so then like there's
always at that episode and then like
dances I feel like Mondays episode
they're like yeah that'd be a swatch
Tuesday yeah it's ready for the next
month right sean is just a wish oh my
gosh can I save my hair the reunion she
is so cute
she's so cute she's petite and little is
she not what happened she's she's cute
everyone is Cameron's love she's
annoying she's so annoying and like I
don't know what she's trying to
accomplish you don't watch the episode I
oh yeah yeah like maybe she just got bad
at it maybe yeah you really never know
yeah true
everyone's probably just nice and lovely
so far everyone we've met like a walk in
the park
yeah maybe let me say mean things about
I mean who do you not like Vanessa from
all day Nick
Sara but she's added like I don't even
know oh she's the worst um should I go
on no Becca Martinez not here for her at
all
Oh somebody asked like why she wasn't on
paradise it's like hello guys she went
public like she has a boyfriend she's
been having a boyfriend well yeah we
heard otherwise but it's fine I'll tell
you what it honestly you would probably
know better than us but we heard that we
heard it from someone who knows better
than all of us
really yeah I'll tell you guys I'm gonna
need to know yeah um just quickly I met
Rachel Lindsay because I met her when
you're James but it was really quick
like in fact you can't talk to the
superstars right and I hung out with her
and she's everything feel like my life
is complete I'm like oh my gosh I met
Rachel Lindsay which is important first
of all she is the coolest girl ever she
is I only want her to think I'm cool
like I need a crave acceptance and the
validation from Rachel Lindsay it's just
once so epic and so smart and she like
makes me feel dumb because she's like
still a lawyer she's like so damn smart
and I just I only want amazing things
for her and Bryan like a life filled
with happiness until they're 90 her ads
are everything she's ever delirious
she's ever like I love you I love her do
people tell you that they remind you of
a life thank you remind them of Alexis
yes yeah just because I'm like your
personality yeah yeah a lot of the girls
from like I've become friends with the
girls we make season and they all say
like you belonged in our season we're
just like you belonged in our scene yeah
I actually thought you were on next
season not all right so weird to
remember what season everyone's from you
have very NIC season which is a good
thing not now yeah hear the good group
of girls I'm dessert undeservedly but
you would you have to make a flight so
we will let you go you have to go to
camp toast but where can people keep up
with you on everything skin-related
and I well I think I'm gonna get into
the whole skin thing IG TV yeah it's
well baby underscore jewels everything
everything is like the same yeah just to
like knocking to make sure to follow for
premium content also make sure you're
following the morning toast because we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on Facebook and YouTube's
make sure you subscribe there we're also
available for those commuters in the
podcast app and I
that's it right if you're looking for
more toast throughout the weekend
patreon.com slash good morning toast
because we will not be back in studio
until Wednesday because its first
roshanda you guys Happy New Year happy
new year make sure to keep up its
morning to us on Instagram all this
weekend if you're coming to camp toast
we can't wait to see you there make sure
you're in the camp trust Facebook group
and I believe that is it sayonara
you